what would you say is the craziest thing  that you've done over the different  seasons and this is really would be  really saying something of American  Horror Story the craziest thing yeah the  thing that was maybe the most disturbing  or felt you to do oh my god the list is  endless  mm-hmm yeah it does seem like they have  there's almost every imaginable thing  they've had you do  yeah and just when you think you've done  it they top it so it's so it's this  season we did the well is the one you're  referring to the Billy Eichner yeah  mm-hmm you didn't need to do that with  your help hey I'm sorry I'm sorry you  can use the clinical term you if you  pleasure yourself  I never Billy Eichner just infers that  very good-looking guy so you had to yeah  do that you didn't have to you got to I  got to it was a pleasure to look him  right in the eye as I don't do that just  keep your hands  [Applause]  you're a perverted mind is what you are  yeah  you